tu sais ce qui se passe là tu tombes
malade et tu vas passer ton tour hein
donc ah je suis pas malade toi tu vas
jouer deux fois de
suite deux tours d'affilé pour retenir
on peut après apprendre à conduire à
partir de 16 ans qu'on travaille à
partir de 16 ans
et qu'on peut conduire tout seul à
partir de 18 ans découvr les règles de
vie en société à travers des jeux
ludiques certes mais pas seulement la
Maison de l'Environnement de Manil et
Hamo a proposé de comparer les
inégalités entre citoyens du monde et de
parler droits de l'homme au plus jeune
tout en s'amusant je trouve que c'est
important de les de les sensibiliser à
notre monde et aussi de voir que il y a
des des pays qui n'ont pas les mêmes
droits que nous cette journée des
rencontres solidaires était organisé en
partenariat avec plusieurs associations
human de l'agglomération j'ai déjà fait
ça avec un groupe de jeunes et ils
onaient bien réagi ils avaient bien
senti un petit peu dans leur presque
dans leur chair cette ces inégalités à
l'issue de ce jeu les enfants ont
adressé des courriers à ces inconnus du
bout du monde pour leur faire part de
leur soutien dans leur combat ce jour-là
la galette des rois aussi se voulait
solidaire